the foundation was in chaos one minute
Dr Wright was looking into some harmless
products on Amazon to help the
foundation's anomalies have a nicer
experience in their cells the next he
was physically fighting for his life
against the company's CEO of course Dr
Bright's wacky Antics have revealed the
location of the SCP foundation's most
valuable containment site to Jeff Bezos
and his Legions of minions does Dr Jack
Bright have it in him to fix his mistake
defeat the mighty Jeff Bezos and save
the SCP Foundation from corporate
servitude of the forces of the SCP
Foundation equal in strength to the
Amazon horde and how at the 11th Hour
will anomalies like scp-096
scp-682
SCP-173 and scp-049 helped save the day
buckle up the only way to find out is to
keep watching the two Titans Dr bright
and the freakishly buffed Jeff Bezos
were locked into an intense struggle the
hapless Immortal tried his best to punch
and kick the augmented CEO but all it
did was make Bezos laugh pathetic Jack
Bezos roared let me show you how a real
man does it with one punch Bezos sent Dr
bright skidding across the dirt seeing
Stars Bezos punched him so hard Dr
bright felt like he'd been hit by a
runaway truck where had he even gotten
all this anomalous technology something
more was going on here but before Dr
Bryant could collect his thoughts Bezos
was already upon him the ruthless
business Mogul clasped his hands
together and brought them down onto the
back of Jack's head in a brutal pile
Drive burying his head in the dirt the
guards of sight 19 looked on in Terror
at the thousands of Amazon troops
surrounding them and they were betting
all this on a fist fight and what's more
it didn't even look like Dr bright was
winning that fight unless the good
doctor used his special move Bezos still
cackling like a Saturday morning cartoon
villain grabbed Dr bright by his hair
and dragged him out of the dirt he
lifted the doctor bloody and bashed with
one hand at that moment Dr Wright knew
that he had to go with the nuclear
option here he needed to use
scp-963 to take over the body of Jeff
Bezos and end this demented War how did
that Bezos said or do you want me to
humiliate you even more in front of your
sad little employees or should I say my
sad little employees
without another word Dr Wright grabbed
the amulet hanging around his neck and
balled it into his fist moving as
quickly as he could he lunged at Bezos
with The Medallion knowing that one
touch should be enough to finish this
whole thing but then the unexpected
happened Bezos caught Dr Bright's hand
the Flesh of the CEO's fists turned
obsidian black he gave a cruel smirk he
was still himself impossible all the SCP
Foundation staff in attendance were
shocked and horrified but none more than
Dr bright himself this was the first
time that scp-963 simply hadn't worked I
I don't understand Jack said voice
trembling as Bezos squeezed his hand
with an iron grip I should have taken
you over how is this possible Bezos
chuckled before unleashing a brutal
headbutt on Dr bright throwing him back
through the air bright was lucky he
managed to keep a grip on The Medallion
this body hadn't worn it for 30 days if
he dropped it it would have just been
another useless necklace Nano machine
son Bezos part cracking his neck back
into place I had them
in anywhere your necklace
necklace my genetics to turn that flesh
into inanimate pseudomound do you think
I'd lead an assault on the SCP
Foundation without planning for every
possible eventuality I've been playing
the long game it was at this point the
foundation guards assembled outside the
building opened fire on Bezos but it was
no use the bullets just ricocheted off
of his anomalously enhanced physique he
just gave a bellowing laugh and ordered
the full strength of his forces to move
in as far as he was concerned the fight
was already won if their forces could
plant the grinning Amazon flag in the
heart of sight 19 the SCP Foundation
would be his it was time for the true
final battle to begin Amazon's troops
loaded their weapons and charged firing
volley after volley of bullets onto the
foundation's guards entrenched in their
positions of course the foundation
Personnel was better trained but the
Amazon Army outnumbered them 10 to 1. it
was only a matter of time until the
barricades gave way and the forces
spilled into the contain facility and
then they did inside the building Dr
clef was reading his new copy of
shotguns a comprehensive guide when the
Army breached the perimeter it was at
this point that he put down the book and
picked up his favorite shotgun a
Remington Model 1187 fun fact also the
preferred weapon of Anton sugar from No
Country for Old Men and entered The Fray
they'd need every SCP Foundation hand on
Deck to repel the incoming attack the
one thing that not even Dr cleff
predicted was for the anomalies to get
involved too you see in ordering his
troops to attack site 19 the fleet of
Amazon Attack Helicopters above began
launching agm-114 Hellfire missiles at
the building to knock out guard towers
and strategic Communications arrays this
however had the unintended effect of
causing power fluctuations within the
building and with so many of the reserve
generators devoted to maintaining
external security against the Amazon
Army internal security failed entirely
in other words a whole lot of cell doors
were popping open a group of Amazon foot
soldiers were making their way down
hallway 6C when they saw something
strange on the ground a tide of green
bubbling chemicals that produced a
horrific smell little did they know this
was powerful hydrochloric acid but in
this instance it wasn't the acid they
should be worried about they heard a
raspy voice behind them say disgusting
that's when they turned to see scp-682
the giant rage-fueled Immortal reptile
standing right behind them it had just
finished its exotic beef jerky
collection and now it was eager for
seconds the Amazon soldiers panicked and
began to open fire on the beast but all
that succeeded in doing was annoying it
scp-682 leaped onto them and began
devouring the group of hapless
mercenaries alive elsewhere in the
facility another group of Amazon
mercenaries were chasing some
defenseless SCP Foundation researchers
through the secure humanoid containment
Wing the researchers tried to run but
soon they were backed into a corner The
Mercenaries laughed and leveled their
assault rifles this would be an easy
kill however the second they tried to
fire they realized something extremely
strange had occurred all of their guns
had turned into delightful bouquets
standing between them and the
researchers they intended to kill was
scp-343 also known to some as God now
now boys
scp-343 said with a slight smile can't
we all just get along Make Love Not War
frightened by these seemingly impossible
act they just witnessed the now unarmed
mercenaries ran into a nearby room with
a sturdy looking door and locked
themselves in hopefully nobody would get
them here that thought was interrupted
by a grandiose voice with an archaic
French accent speaking out behind them
why hello there good sirs so kind of you
to step into my practice today they
turned and saw a strange robed man
wearing a runner pigeon mask the figure
removed the mask only to reveal what
seemed like another strange beaked mask
underneath it was scp-049 his desk
covered in pleasingly polished Amazon
medical tools my my Eugen seem a little
under the weather this is cause for
concern the plague doctor said as he
began to walk towards the frightened
mercenaries the pestilence runs right
days not to worry though I am an expert
and I've been itching to try out my
lovely new tools horrified screaming was
heard from the room shortly after then
silence but Amazon troops kept pouring
in it was an all-out assault Beyond any
that site 19 had ever experienced some
Amazon strike teams were making their
way through the break rooms hunting for
more Foundation employees to capture or
execute one of them remarked that these
SCP Foundation employees must be real
head cases why else would they keep such
hideous concrete sculptures in their
break room utterly bizarre the second
they found there was no one inside and
turned to leave the room they all laid
dead on the ground with snapped necks
that would make its 17 Amazon
mercenaries they'd killed today the
sculpture was having a truly wonderful
time meanwhile over in his office Dr
cleff was fighting for his life a group
of Junior researchers were taking refuge
and they're with him and handing him
shotgun shells from his many many boxes
of them when he needed to reload Soldier
after Soldier was running into the room
and clef was using his trusty Remington
pump action to blow them away with
Incredible Precision every time one of
them ran in an austruck researcher asked
how are you this good with that thing
clef laughed and said kid I could
unbutton your lab coat with it but then
tragedy struck Dr clef ran out of shells
he signed and told the assembled
researchers to run out of the back exit
and save themselves he'd hold back the
tide of Amazon mercenaries alone he
kissed his shotgun and said forgive me
for this Remy then grabbed it by the
barrel if he couldn't shoot with it he'd
at least use it as a club he ran out
into The Fray bashing down mercenaries
left and right with his shotgun Club
until he was finally outnumbered a group
of heavily armed soldiers surrounded him
holding him at gunpoint one of them gave
the order to fire wait Dr clef said I
can be valuable to you you don't know
who I am do you give me a second let me
show you my ID Dr clef pulled an id1
from his lab coat and then showed it to
the soldiers they looked at it confused
and a little Disturbed the leader of the
group said that's not an ID card you
schmuck what the hell is that ugly thing
anyway by this point Dr Cliff had
already closed his eyes a distant
screaming got closer and closer until
the wall of his office exploded
scp-096 entered the room shrieking with
rage and began tearing the hapless
soldiers to shreds Cliff rolled away
keeping his eyes closed and waiting for
the Carnage to be over but in a grander
sense the Carnage had only just begun oh
and for those who were curious yes
scp-811 did get her blobfish plushie she
loved it outside the facility Jeff Bezos
looked upon the destruction he rocked
and laughed it was just as wonderful as
he did mentioned it in all his years of
intense planning for this very moment it
all unfolded exactly to his design the
SCP Foundation would fall and his master
plan would finally be complete Dr Jack
Bright demoralized but not defeated Roe
shakely to his feet this whole disaster
had been his fault he had to redeem this
he had to defeat Jeff Bezos or the
foundation would fall into his iron
clutches even if it finally truly killed
him Dr bright would not give up
impressive tack Dr bright said cracking
his knuckles and getting Jeff's
attention again which Sweatshop built it
for you Jeff just laughed and turned to
Bright again more than ready for round
two a little place called Prometheus
Labs Jack Jeff said remember them I was
on the board of directors before the
incident just like you and your
foundation dogs they left behind plenty
of goodies for me Dr bright charged at
Bezos screaming in animal Fury he
punched the smug anomalous businessman
Square in the jaw Bezos barely even
flinched he gave Jack an utterly brutal
open-handed slap knocking him towards
the entrance to site 19 where more
Amazon soldiers were still pouring in
still Jack began to stand again what
the hell does a corporate stiff like you
want with the SCP Foundation he said we
want to help the world not rule it Bezos
sneered and began stomping towards the
immortal doctor I don't just want to
rule the world Jack I want to hold it in
my hand like an apple and take a big
juicy bite all that exists will belong
to me he said throwing a punch that Dr
bright was thankfully able to dodge
that's always been the plan and the SCP
Foundation is the final piece I need Dr
bright summoning all the adrenaline in
his body Unleashed a flurry of sharp
punches to Jeff's abdomen he simply
tanked every strike and laughed I've
been funding the chaos Insurgency for
years Jack I'm one of Marshall Carter
and Doc's largest shareholders Amazon is
Dr wondertainment's primary Global
distributor the sarkists the fifthists
the mechanites those pretentious art
snobs are we cool yet they're all in my
Deep Pockets Jeff roard he wrapped one
of his massive hands around Dr Bright's
throats and lifted him clear off the
ground Jack struggled against his grip
you've spent decades worrying about all
the wrong things Jack Jeff said slowly
tightening his grip around Dr Bright's
throat the Devourer of Worlds the black
moon the Scarlet King my new world won't
have a king it'll have a CEO and with
The Power Within These Walls I'll be the
chairman of the cosmic board and it all
starts with me killing you and turning
your silly little necklace into a
paperweight but Jack had an ace up his
sleeve something he had the good sense
to pocket before facing pesos on the
battlefield he reached into his lab coat
and pulled out
scp-662 the butler's handbell one little
ring and Mr Deeds suddenly appeared
right next to them Jack barely managed
to wheeze out
kick Jeff in the groin of course sir Mr
Deeds said before doing exactly that
Jeff Winston Payne and loosened his grip
on Dr bright snack the Plucky Immortal
took his chance to wriggle free from
Jeff's grip and run into the facility
yelling back deed stall him but before
Deeds could execute this order Jeff
Bezos fractured the anomalous Butler's
skull with a single punch and chased Dr
bright into the facility he would have
his revenge as Dr bright fled he'd
grabbed his foundation walkie-talkie and
frantically spoke into it Cliff I'm in
big trouble I think I have a way to stop
this but there's just something you need
to do for me first battles were raging
throughout the site some Amazon soldiers
had unloaded their rifles into Kane only
to find themselves on the floor dying of
massive blood loss other squadrons of
mercenaries were being tortured by the
nightmarish scp-106 in his terrifying
pocket Dimension he was having a
wonderful time
scp-999 was even tickling a gaggle of
Amazon's hired veteran war criminals
into absolute submission much to Jeff's
rage and horror it looked like with the
help of the anomalies the foundation
might actually be able to turn the tide
this would not do he'd destroy bright
and take care of the rest personally it
has to be this way Jack Bezos yelled
after the fleeing doctor I'm making the
mother of all corporate omelets here
can't fret over a few ransacked
containment sites bezos's
self-aggrandizing rants were interrupted
by a cp682 leaping onto him out of an
adjoining hallway giving Dr bright even
more time to create distance between
them 682 fought valiantly and viciously
but Jeff's Prometheus Labs Nano machine
augmentations gave him the edge he was
able to get to scp-682 into a headlock
Steve Irwin style then punch it in the
head until it was knocked out Jeff's
side relieved and continued to chase
after Jack as Jeff turned a corner to
chase Dr bright he ran right into one of
Jack's traps there was Dr bright
standing about 15 feet away from
holding his favorite item that he
normally wasn't allowed to use the
chainsaw Cannon Jack smirkton said smile
you son of a boom a chainsaw projectile
blasted towards Jeff at incredible
speeds it was through pure luck and
superhuman reflexes that Jeff was able
to catch it between his palms by the
blade and hold it in place even as it
cut into his nanite hardened skin with
the grunt of Rage he threw the saw into
the ground is that all you got Jack he
growled not quite Dr bright replied I've
got a few friends who owe me some favors
suddenly Bezos heard footsteps behind
him he turned to see three figures
standing there primed and ready for
battle
scp-4494 the Specter
scp-5151 the Black Knight and scp-2800
Cactus man you'll fight without honor
Sir Jeffrey the Black Knight proclaimed
as he drew his long sword I and I can't
stand bullies said cactus man as the
spikes began to grow wage theft and tax
evasion is a crime evil doer the Specter
added well then Jeff said I suppose I'll
just have to kill you all the fight
began a group of four Heroes held their
own impressively to begin with they
consistently helped each other block or
avoid the deadly strikes that Bezos was
unleashing and returning their own four
anomalies against one the Black Knight
even gave Dr bright one of his spare
swords to give him a better chance of
Landing a meaningful blow against Bezos
but in the end it was all for nothing
Bezos powered up his Nano machines
drawing energy from the building around
him until he was even larger and
stronger in his State he easily beat
down his four attackers incapacitating
them and standing over bright it's
useless Jack he said with another evil
laugh you can't beat me I Know Jack
groaned in pain but I did a pretty good
job of stalling you at that moment clef
came running down the hall wielding
another firearm but it wasn't a shotgun
this time in fact it didn't even look
like a real gun it looked like a
spray-painted Nerf gun that got another
laugh out of Jeff what an utterly feeble
attempt that's when Dr clef leveled the
Nerf gun and fired one of its starts
against Jeff's chest where it seemed to
bounce off uselessly really he asked
incredulous come on this is just getting
his words were cut off by an uppercut
from Dr bright inexplicably he actually
felt that one Jeff staggered back
rubbing his jaw as bright Rose to his
feet how the hell did you hurt me Jeff
muttered genuinely shocked Dr bright
smirked that was the nerfing gun
chromedome we just made your precious
Nano machines useless with another
incredibly well-earned punch in the face
from Dr bright Jeff was down on the
ground with a bleeding nose elsewhere in
the facility the researchers guards and
anomalies working together had defeated
the dark Forces of Amazon outside hammer
town the largest and most militarily
powerful mobile task force had arrived
and wiped out what remained of Jeff's
Invasion Force outside it wasn't easy
but the SCP Foundation had won as Jeff
lay on the ground holding his broken
nose Dr bright held him at sword Point
wait wait Jeff said that's not let hard
feelings linger we're both adults right
and I'm a businessman I make deals
compromises I can give you anything from
the Amazon stock free of charge as long
as we agree that I can go and we forget
all about this Dr bright smiled and
thought it over well he said there are
few things I'd like for myself and there
are still plenty more anomalies that
need enriching Victory secured want
another video about the deranged things
Dr bright bought for even more anomalies
and Foundation staff let us know down in
the comments and we'll continue the
strangest story that the SCP
foundation's most eccentric researcher
ever told now go check out SCP Edition
weird things on Amazon Dr Bright's great
idea and as cp001 when day breaks Dr
bright for more of the Mad Doctor's most
peculiar Adventures